le gouvernement rocard menacé par le
vote de la motion censure sur la loi
d'aministie le parti communiste front
longe le suspense réponse possible dans
quelques minutes
reportages débats et analyses dans
direct nouvel arsenal dans l'expression
et de prévention le gouvernement part en
guerre contre le trafic de drogue et
contre le blanchiment de l'argent
frederik de klerk à paris c'est le début
d'une tournée diplomatique en europe
pour le président sud africain il sera
reçu demain à l'elysée enfin michel
platini et les joueurs de l'as
saint-etienne dans le box des accusés au
centre de la sphère l'argent sale du
football de lyon compte rendu d'audience
bonsoir la bonne nouvelle n'est pas
encore parvenu à l'assemblée nationale
qui vit un nouveau psychodrame
mais l'exploit de nos cheminots mérite
un coup de chapeau du 19 20
la bonne nouvelle c'est leur record
mondial battu par le tgv 500 10,6 km
heure c'était cet après midi à 17 heures
le train à grande vitesse français
pulvérisé son propre record sur la ligne
courtalain tour un très bon point pour
la conquête du marché sud-coréen chant
jacques perron ram 325 du tgv celle là
même qui avait battu le précédent record
de vitesse en décembre dernier mais au
lieu d'afficher 480 2,4 km heure le
compteur cet après midi à 17 heures et
monter à 500 10,6 record toutes
catégories pulvérisé d'autant plus
exemplaire que ce tgv n'est pas comme
son concurrent allemand à prototype mais
une rame tout à fait semblable à celle
qui transportent des voyageurs sur le
réseau atlantique
à titre de comparaison rappelons que la
vitesse atteinte tout à l'heure était
celle d'un avion de ligne dans les
années 60 à l'époque tous les ingénieurs
affirmé qu'un train ne dit pas serait
jamais 250 km heure aujourd'hui c'est
plus du double tout le monde peut se
tromper
étrange coïncidence pour michel rocard
le premier ministre fêtera demain 10 mai
1990 le deuxième anniversaire de son
installation à matignon mais le mot
fêter est il vraiment approprié michel
rocard attendra sans doute ce soit
l'issue du débat qui a lieu en ce moment
même à l'assemblée sur la motion de
censure avant de déboucher
éventuellement une bouteille de
champagne
il ne le fera que si les communistes
décident de ne pas voter la motion de
censure déposée par l'opposition vous
avez entendu jacques chirac à 19 heures
écoutons la réponse du premier ministre
à l'instant je continuerai expliqué que
la démocratie est un coot et qu'il faut
la financer a expliqué que l'écrasante
majorité des élus de son de ce pays est
composé de femmes et d'hommes dévoué et
honnêtes a expliqué que ceux qui ont dû
et luz ou professionnels mais connaître
des règles inadaptées n'avait pas à
payer seul le prix de l'hypocrisie de
tous a expliqué que la loi doit
appliquer ces rigueur pour l'avenir à
tous ceux qui l'auront méconnu mais
réservé c'est même rigueur pour le passé
seulement à ceux qui se serait rendue
coupable d' enrichissement personnel
les déclarations des principaux acteurs
n'ont pas encore mis fin au suspense que
le parti communiste entretient
délibérément depuis plusieurs jours
ambiance autour de l'hémicycle
jérôme cathala aide mais poupart extrême
chaleur le thermomètre de l'assemblée
nationale est formel la soirée sera
chaude très chaude dans l'hémicycle
comme dans les couloirs les députés ce
conte et les partis fourbissent leurs
armes derrière les sourires ou les
sombres visages
une seule question pour tous faut-il
croire à la censure
vedette incontestée de ce suspense
politique les communistes bien sûr avec
andré lajoinie
nous allons rester tout le débat ici
écoutent écouter tous les députés
écoutez les écouter les réponses sont à
notre proposition de loi
constitutionnelle fait et en fonction de
ces réponses là nous nous réunirons
comité central et députés
la décision qui sera prise pour le vote
de ce soir va t-elle en clair ou bien
michel rocard répond favorablement à la
proposition communiste visant à
interdire dans la constitution
l'amnistié politique ou bien les députés
du pc votre la censure c'est qui
paradoxalement reçoit l'approbation d'un
députés de l'udf
le srec os je réfléchirai parce que
toute façon ils ont à l'étiage la
sécheresse absolue alors vous donne pas
la voter autre pièce maîtresse dans la
partie qui se joue à l'assemblée les
centristes de l'ue décès ils ont clamé
tout l'après midi leur unanimité et
votre ou comme un seul homme la motion
essentiellement pour des raisons de
morale liée à l'amnistié surtout à la
sphère nucci bien moi j'ai fait appel au
gouvernement pour qu'il clarifie la
situation fait appel au gouvernement
pour qu'il sorte le report nucci il ne
l'a pas fait donc aujourd'hui chacun
prend ses responsabilités mais en
attendant si la tension monte dans les
couloirs de l'assemblée
c'est bien vers la place du colonel
fabien que se tournent les regards est
précisément le comité central du parti
communiste est réunie en ce moment même
place du colonel fabien son vote ce soir
à 21h30 dépendra en grande partie de
l'attitude de michel rocard et de celle
des partis politiques et de la réponse
que ces partis ferrante à sa proposition
vous l'avez compris le parti communiste
souhaite une réforme de la constitution
qui interdirait à l'avenir toute
amnistie d'hommes politiques ayant
détourné des sommes politique et de
l'argent à des fins personnelles at il
une chance d'être entendu michel lemaire
oui pole ici à l'assemblée nationale
officiellement le suspense continue
mais on a bien le sentiment depuis
l'intervention de michel rocard qu'on va
plutôt vers une baisse de tension
d'avant les communistes ont critiqué
avec tant de vigueur cet après midi à
l'opposition qu'on les voit mal ce soir
voté une motion de censure à leurs côtés
et puis surtout pendant son intervention
michel rocard n'a pas répondu très
directement à cette demande de loi
constitutionnelle il ne veut pas avoir
de tête politique à l'égard du parti
communiste mais il a dit néanmoins qu'il
avait vu divers propositions qui ont été
faites et qu'il ne voyait aucun
inconvénient au contraire à en accélérer
l'examen
alors c'est un texte très important pour
le
la suite du débat car il retrouve là une
idée qu'ont exprimé les communistes qui
au fond du plus jamais ça
l'idée centrale s'est il y a eu bien
entendu les dérapages maintenant on a
une nouvelle loi sur le financement des
partis politiques
il ne faut plus le gouvernement les
d'accord qu'on puisse a retrouvé ses
dérapages et il faut donc durcir ses
textes répressifs donc il y a
manifestement là un terrain d'accord si
pour le saura sans doute dans quelques
instants car andré lajoinie pourrait
passer également à l'assemblée nationale
si c'est vraiment ce scénario qui est
retenu et qui est le plus probable
il y aura sans doute un grand ouf de
soulagement chez certains centristes qui
vivait assez mal le débat ou bien lâcher
leur groupe ou bien le créer une crise
politique andré la jolie se trouve
actuellement à l'autre bout de paris
dans le 20ème arrondissement place du
colonel fabien jérôme cathala et jean
marc pitte s'y trouve précisément si le
parti communiste annonce une décision et
nous appellerons bien sûr au cours de ce
19 à notre côté nous suivrons avec
michel lemaire l'évolution des débats à
l'assemblée nationale et nous
n'hésiterons pas à intervenir mais je
vous propose d'écouter les autres
événements de du jour avec élise lucet à
commencer par le sport à la société de
la coupe d'europe pour box des accusés
michel platini robert herbin et les
joueurs de l'as saint-etienne
comparaissait aujourd'hui devant le
tribunal correctionnel de lyon au centre
de la sphère l'argent sale du football
et près de 22 millions de francs de
détourner l'avocat de michel platini qui
a déjà demandé la relaxe de son client
compte rendu d'audience de notre envoyé
spécial à lyon caroline side 8 ans a
pris à bord donné sa démission l'ex
président de la ssu roger rocher vient
s'expliquer sur la caisse noire
tous les hommes qui ont construit la
grande équipe des verts réunis à nouveau
mais pour un match bien particulier la
vedette c'est ni michel platini
l'ex-meneur de l'équipe de france
abordez-vous ce procès bien relax et
merci
sorin est la conscience en cuivre et
vous faut des tentes pour certains
d'autres en revanche sont moins bavard
robert herbin mérite toujours son surnom
de smile premier événement de ce procès
l'équipe des verts presque au complet
deux joueurs accusés mentales apei mac
os et piazza première curiosité sur les
cinq parties civiles trois se désiste
première surprise
à l'énoncé de la situation
professionnelle des joueurs deux sont au
chômage lario c'est janvion et les 7000
francs mensuels de farizon font triste
mine à côté des trois cent mille francs
minimum déclarer par platini grandeur et
décadence au delà du procès de problème
de la reconversion est posée ici
lorsqu'on voit notamment des joueurs qui
ont maintenant une reconversion
quelquefois difficiles les mettre encore
en phase ii d'un tribunal
et c'est très dur pour eux michel
hidalgo est venu témoigner sur une
grande équipe des verts qu'il ne peut
pas oublier
l'audience du jour est consacré aux
structures de là et c'est ce pourquoi il
y avait une multiplication des organes
et test pour couvrir les finances de la
caisse noire
d'un côté de la salle les joueurs de
l'autre l'équipe dirigeante
la parole est à ces derniers roger
rocher décrit comme un narcissique a
déjà purgé quatre mois de prison en 83
il revendique d'entrée sa responsabilité
dans la caisse noire j'aurais pu dire
non et je n'en serais pas là
77 était la grande époque des verts il a
voulu préserver le standing de son
équipe s'est associé disent toutes
ignorées
le succès serait monté à la tête de leur
président qui aurait agi en dictateur ce
soir roche et rocher est un homme de
plus en plus isolé lâché par tous ses
collaborateurs il est le seul à
revendiquer la responsabilité d'une
caisse noire
mais demain lui et ses associés devront
répondre de la provenance de ces fonds
occultes
les joueurs eux ne rentrerons dans le
jeu que la semaine prochaine
arsenal de répression lutte contre le
blanchiment de l'argent campagne de
mobilisation et renforcement des
structures d'accueil pour les
toxicomanes
gouvernement a lancé ce matin un plan
d'action de grande envergure contre la
drogue
plusieurs ministères sont concernés pour
mener cette véritable guerre contre les
narcotrafiquants détails de ces
nouvelles mesures
laurence piquet premier volet la
répression priorité à la lutte contre le
blanchiment de capitaux
une innovation les organismes financiers
devront déclarer toutes les opérations
jugées suspectes aux banquiers de décidé
la levée du secret bancaire aux
banquiers de signaler les transactions
illicites à une cellule chargée de
coordonner l'action du ministère de
l'économie et des finances une cellule
qui devra travailler étroitement avec un
deuxième organisme l'office central pour
la répression de la grande délinquance
financière qui dépend lui du ministère
de l'intérieur
en fin de deuxième volet capital le
renforcement de la prévention
parmi les objectifs une meilleure prise
en charge des toxicomanes
dès l'année prochaine 200 places
nouvelles créées pour le traitement des
drogués 50 nouveaux points d'accueil et
d'écouté seront ouverts pour les
familles dans les trois ans appellent à
la mobilisation le 26 juin prochain
journée internationale de lutte contre
la drogue journée pour tous ceux qui ont
des réponses à apporter dans ce domaine
ça allait me la police ou la justice mme
des finances ce sont les français les
jeunes les parents les enseignants les
mecs en c1 qu'ils gagneront la lutte
continue
voilà pour l'aspect officiel de la lutte
contre la drogue l'autre face de la
médaille malheureusement c'est le drame
quotidien vécu par les toxicomanes et
par leur famille souvenez vous il y a
quelques semaines nous vous parlions des
folles de madrid ces femmes qui
descendent dans la rue pour lutter
contre les trafiquants et protéger leurs
enfants
ému par ce reportage de mer de
toxicomanes à créteil ont voulu elle
aussi témoigné elles ont tenu à sortir
du silence et de la solitude pour aider
d'autres familles
reportage anne rongère et robin teboul
une mère et son fils au petit déjeuner
une scène apparemment banale mais pour
claudette et tony ces gestes timide ces
regards furtifs c'est déjà énorme car
ils sortent de six ans de silence six
ans de galère comme ils disent tony ce
drogué haschich héroïne cocaïne est
rentré dans la maison est cassé pot pour
la maison tout ce qui est tout ce que
j'aimais enfin parce que tout ce que
j'aimais par exemple les fleurs les vad
tout ce que j'aimais le cas c est à une
violence physique contre vous ah oui le
crachin
puisque la police est venue plusieurs
fois j'ai cherché avec ma mère c'était
vraiment de plan et le poisson mais je
t'aurais c'était comme une bête à cornes
le quad un truc c'est à dire y avait de
l'agressivité on voulait pu moi je
voulais plus de trucs six ans de
violence et d'incompréhension mutuelle
pour josette le rejet par la famille et
les voisins plus souterrain mais tout
aussi destructeurs un énorme sentiment
de culpabilité
on a de la honte de l'angoissent de la
culpabilité parce qu'on se dit mais il
ya quelque chose qu'à des routes s et ça
va plus dans la famille il ya quelque
chose qui va pas alors on se pose plein
de questions
et puis on essaie de cacher ce cachet à
quelques immeubles de claudette josette
presque le même âge et le même
itinéraire
elle a d'abord mis la pâleur et la
longueur de son fils sur le compte de la
fatigue
et puis au bout de six mois trop tard
dit elle elle a compris la drogue
cocaïne - tout ce qui peut se mettre
dans un bras quoi le bien que ça l'a tué
là je pouvais pu mentir le mensonge le
silence la violence
josette on a souffert pendant neuf mois
jusqu'au jour où en parlant avec
d'autres mères elle a compris qu'il lui
fallait briser le cercle vicieux
culpabilité reproche quand il dit je me
casse parce que tu comprends rien je
suis qu'il peut être cassé mais la porte
sera ouverte et il revenait il vit
toujours
c'est une chose que je dis qu'être est
très importante
toujours laissé la porte ouverte dans
n'importe quel état parce que on les
sauve mais on se sauve aussi nous mêmes
on les retrouve en on retrouve le goût
de vivre
ce geste furtif mais tendre de son fils
c'est pour josette le symbole de la
conscience retrouver sa première
victoire sur la drogue
les temps changent il était indésirable
il ya quelques mois il ne l'est plus
aujourd'hui le président sud africain de
fer qui est en visite à paris
il entame une tournée diplomatique en
europe et il tentera bien sûr d'obtenir
la levée des sens des sanctions
économiques à l'encontre de son pays le
président de claques sera ensuite demain
par françois mitterrand et michel rocard
c'est la première fois depuis quarante
trois ans c'est-à-dire depuis la mise en
place de l'apartheid qu'un président sud
africain sera reçu à l'elysée portrait
hubert coudurier
le gouvernement français avait ignoré
son prédécesseur lors des deux visites
privées qu'il fit dans le nord en
commémoration des victimes
sud-africaines des deux guerres
certes frédéric de claire témoigne lui
d'une audace et d'une ténacité lui ayant
permis de réaliser ce que pieter botha
n'avait pu entreprendre quand il lui
succède à la tête du parti national
avant de le pousser vers la sortie en
outre 89
frédéric de claire n'est pourtant qu'à
conservateur pragmatique pur produit de
l'establishment afrikaner mais il va
surprendre tout le monde lors d'un
discours au parlement le 2 février
dernier
en légalisant toutes les organisations
anti apartheid au premier rang desquels
la haine c'est surtout il libère son
chef historique nelson mandela
emprisonné depuis 27 ans décision
éminemment symbolique qui frappent
l'opinion internationale l'afrique du
sud
bouge enfin on parle de pretoria straika
et certains le comparent à gorbatchev
mais ce n'est que le début les
négociations ouvertes la semaine
dernière dans un bon climat doivent
concrétiser la suppression de
l'apartheid à travers des réformes
politiques
la tâche est seulement amorcé que les
extrémistes veulent faire capoter le
processus
toutefois de claire qui a trouvé un
mandela un interlocuteur providentiel
apparaît déjà comme l'homme ayant eu le
courage de rompre 40 ans d'immobilisme
on y verrait c'est traditionnellement le
9 mai non le 8 mai que se déroule
anniversaire officiel de la victoire sur
l'allemagne nazie
commémoration et parade militaire en
lituanie la cérémonie s'est déroulée
sous haute surveillance a signalé
quelques incidents mais dit
lituanie ont en effet manifesté
troublant l'ordre du défilé l'armée
soviétique est intervenu parfois un peu
violemment comme vous le voyez sur ces
images il n'y a eu en revanche aucun
incident en lettonie mais la cérémonie
s'est déroulée dans un climat très tendu
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
hélène risacher et joseph tual notre
choix du socialisme et la bonne voie
nous avons besoin de l'armée pour
réussir notre unification socialiste
rejeté tous les nationalismes nous
devons garder tous les peuples du rss en
paix pour le général kousmine ce
commandant des forces armées de la
région baltes la lettonie s'appelle
toujours républiques socialistes
soviétiques de lettonie humiliante
matinée pour les membres du nouveau
gouvernement indépendantiste lecteurs
qui assiste aux cérémonies militaires le
chef du gouvernement le président du
parlement et le vice premier ministre
ont dû montrer leurs papiers avant de
monter à la tribune le défilé officiel
en l'honneur du 9 mai 45 victoire sur le
nazisme a duré une vingtaine de minutes
28 unités des trois armes dont les
fameuses troupes de combat qui circulent
en ce moment dans les rues de riga
ensuite une cinquantaine de blindés des
transports de troupes d'orgues de
staline de missiles et pour la première
fois après l'hymne du rss alors
qu'istres militaire n'a pas joué l'hymne
de lettonie oui je me suis sentie
insultée parce que le général a parlé de
république soviétique de lettonie il a
utilisé des mots aussi extrémiste que
les nationalistes extrémistes
nous devons établir progressivement de
nouvelles relations avec l'armée
soviétique
nous devons faire comprendre à moscou
que l'armée soviétique toute une armée
étrangère ici je dis bien une armée
étrangère
après le défilé quelques milliers d'anti
indépendantiste fidèles à moscou ont
manifesté leur message nous ne
laisserons pas la lettonie quitter
l'union soviétique
ambiance plus crispé à vilnius en
lituanie tout le centre ville est bouclé
et le défilé a eu lieu sous haute
surveillance et sur invitation avec un
discours musclé du commandant de la
région de vilnius le général ovtcharov
la situation est difficile
l'armée rouge combattre à toutes les
tentatives nationaliste
pour briser l'union soviétique le danger
de guerre existe touchés nous devons
garder notre puissance intacte dans
toute l'ue à la cesse at il conclu le
chapitre social maintenant on les
appelait les bouche trous puis comme ils
sont devenus de plus en plus nombreux on
leur a donné le nom d'intérimaires ou de
cdd
le patronat a même créé l'exploit
pression emplois atypiques pour
contrebalancer celle d'emplois précaires
utilisé par les syndicats c'est pour
tenter de limiter les abus en matière
d'emploi précaire justement que jean
pierre soisson a présenté ce matin un
projet de loi en conseil des ministres
claude bellot c'est un coup franc de
terminer un mois après je suis un
contrat de sabine et de trois mois après
pour endetter faut pas déterminé de mal
que de 24 heures et après je passe entre
auteurs de contrat à durée déterminée à
période d'intérim en passant par des
phases de chômage ils sont un million
comme cette caissière de supermarché
pour lesquelles travailler rime avec
galéré l'emploi précaire ou atypiques
par opposition à leur poids stable
concerne aujourd'hui 7 % des salariés
deux fois plus qu'il ya cinq ans ce qui
devait être l'exception est devenue peu
à peu la règle avec une embauche ferme
pour hui contrats temporaires l'emploi
précaire est fortement représentée dans
le commerce le bâtiment ou l'automobile
11% l'intérimaire par exemple chez
citroën
l'objectif du ministre du travail de
mettre fin aux abus
à travers une nouvelle loi plus
restrictive qui sera discuté à la fin du
mois au parlement
mais sur ce terrain jean pierre soisson
est pris en tenaille avec d'un côté le
cnpf qui entend préserver la possibilité
pour les entreprises de recourir aux cdd
et à l'intérim et de l'autre le parti
socialiste partisan comme la cgt et
force ouvrière une loi plus sévère
pascal justice vous présente les autres
événements de la journée couvert par
toutes les stations régionales de l'a3
accident d'avion dans le cher un petit
avion école s'est écrasé ce matin près
de la commune de pigny l'élève pilote et
son moniteur ont trouvé la mort une
enquête est en cours pour déterminer les
causes de l'accident
drame familial à guebwiller dans le haut
rhin une femme avoue avoir tué son mari
avec l'aide de ses deux enfants
le cadavre a été retrouvé calciné dans
leur voiture non loin de la maison après
avoir endormi puis frappé la victime la
mère et son fils de 18 ans l'avait
transporté dans le véhicule avant d'y
mettre feu selon les enquêteurs l'homme
était un habitué des bistrots et ne
rendait pas la vie facile aux siens 5000
agents des ptt rassemblés cet après-midi
à paris à proximité de leur ministère
ils manifestaient contre le projet qu'il
est qui prévoit la séparation des postes
et télécommunications le projet sera
débattu demain à l'assemblée nationale
fin de la grève de l'institut national
de l'audiovisuel
après un mois de conflit le personnel de
l'ina a obtenu une augmentation moyenne
annuelle de 1600 francs soit 3000 francs
pour les bas salaires et 1000 francs
pour les cadres
et de trois pour didier auriol pour la
troisième fois consécutive le champion
automobile a remporté le tour de corse
il devance l'espagnol carlos sainz de
trente six petites secondes et cela
malgré plusieurs en 8 mécanique
un bon point pour lancia dans le
championnat du monde des rallyes
reportage en corse jean pierre frick aux
orioles occelli en remportant cet après
midi leur troisième tour de corse
consécutive rejoignent au palmarès
darniche my une sacrée référence qui
prend toute sa valeur quand on sait qu
après avoir dominé 5 après l'élimination
loubet auriol a failli ce matin tout
perdre à quatre chronos de l'arrivée ils
cassent un différentiel terminus est
presque tout le bénéfice d'une superbe
course j'avais que 24 secondes et rien
n'était joué et j'ai il a fait je le
prends sur moi pour avoir envie de
rattaquer de de conserver cette première
place mais j'étais pas j'avais un petit
peu la crainte de de trois attaques et
de faire une faute parce que c'était
vraiment très très chaud
une fois tous les mécanos de l'ancien
pont des miracles est le talon d'auriol
fait le reste ils comptèrent la victoire
pour 36 secondes et accroît son avantage
au championnat du monde sur l'espagnol
sainz et sa toyota une pâte plus second
à la troisième place à triaud fait la
bonne affaire au championnat de france
en devançant sa vie
en groupe n balesi s'impose devant
oreille et enfin carton plein à la régie
renault
enfin il faut saluer la performance de
poggi sur la petite ax sur son terrain
il termine 6e de ce tour de corse
toujours aussi beau
je
les ministres continuent d'entretenir le
suspense le comité central du parti
communiste français est toujours réunis
place du colonel fabien il étudiait
attentivement le discours que le premier
ministre vient de faire et il donnera sa
réponse sans doute au cours de la soirée
en tout cas avant 21h30 alors à laquelle
tous les députés voteront pour ou contre
la motion de censure qui a déposé
l'opposition à l'initiative de jacques
chirac je vous le rappelle cette motion
de censure est approuvée par une
majorité absolue de parlementaire
c'est-à-dire par 289 parlementaire le
gouvernement de michel rocard sera
renversée tout dépend donc de l'attitude
du parti communiste français qui doit
prendre une décision très importante
peut-être spectaculaire ce soir mais le
comité central est lui même divisé c'est
que c'est ce qui explique la longueur la
durée des discussions qui ont lieu à
l'autre bout de paris
à l'autre bout de l'assemblée nationale
place du colonel fabien nos envoyés
spéciaux
jérôme cathala et jean marc pitte je
trouve place du colonel fabien
ils interviendront évidemment au cours e
d édition de la soirée au cours de soir
3 plus exactement
michel lemaire se trouve quant à lui à
l'assemblée nationale le débat devrait
reprendre au tout début de la soirée la
soirée sur l'a3 dans quelques instants
la classe suivi d'une grande soirée
variétés à commencer par le 5e festival
de la chanson française présentée par
jean louis foulquier avec notamment
renault francis cabrel ou bernard
lavilliers suivi de mille bravos
prochain rendez-vous est l'info c'est à
22h10 soir 3 présenté par mémona
hintermann bon choirat demain 19h et à
ce soir 22 heures 15
d